ALANA WEISS: Good morning.
My name is Alana Weiss, and
today it is my pleasure to
welcome Adam Grant to the
Leading at Google series.
Adam Grant is the youngest
tenured professor and single
highest rated teacher at
the Wharton School.
He is a former record setting
advertising director, junior
Olympic springboard diver, and
professional magician.
He has been honored as one of
"Business Week's" favorite
professors and one of the
world's top 40 business
professors under 40.
Adam is a regular contributor
to Google's People &
Innovation lab, and he also
has consulted with clients
ranging from the NFL
to Goldman Sachs
to the United Nations.
He holds a Ph.D in
organizational psychology from
the University of Michigan and
a BA from Harvard University.
Today, Adam will share from his
new book "Give and Take."
Please join me in welcoming
Adam Grant.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM GRANT: Good morning.
Thank you guys so much
for having me.
I'm truly delighted
to be here.
It's always an honor and a treat
to speak to Googlers,
and also to see lots
of friendly
faces in the audience.
And I'm going to try to turn all
of those friendly faces in
a more negative direction
in the next few minutes.
The place I want to start is I
want to talk for maybe 35 or
40 minutes or so.
We'll have lots of interactive
discussion throughout, and
then hopefully open it up then
for some questions and more
discussion.
But the place to begin, really,
is to say that I'm
interested in success and what
makes some people and
organizations incredibly
productive and effective and
why other people, perhaps,
are less so.
And at the end of the day, what
I want to know is how can
every person in this room own
a face that looks like this?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: And I know some of
you are thinking right now,
well, I already own that face.
And the question is, well, how
could you own it more often?
Or how could you spread it to
the other people around you?
And as an organizational
psychologist, when I started
doing research in this area
about 10 years ago, I found
that there were three ways
to get to this face--
hard work, talent, and luck.
If you want to be effective in
any domain or any profession
or any field, you have to
develop a strong work ethic,
you have to really be mastery or
expertise oriented so that
you develop true skills, and, as
Malcolm Gladwell told us in
"Outliers," you have to find
yourself in the right place at
the right time.
And I think that's all true.
But for me, it was missing a
really important part of
success in this connected world
that we all live in--
our interactions with others.
Most of you work in teams.
Many of you have clients.
Some of you have more managers
than you would like, perhaps.
And the question is, how does
the way that you interact with
those people every day, shape
the results that you achieve,
the promotions that you gain?
And ultimately, perhaps also the
meaning in the happiness
that you obtain.
So when I was trying to get to
the bottom of this, I came
across a really inspiring
quote.
It was from Robert Benchley.
And Benchley said there are only
two kinds of people in
the world--
those who divide the world into
two kinds of people, and
those who don't.
And I thought that was a
really profound way of
criticizing those of us in the
psychology world who like to
oversimplify all of the richness
and complexity of
human beings.
And I told myself that if I
ever wrote a book I would
never dumb down all of the
complexity of people into just
two categories.
Which is why today I am proud to
announce to you that if you
want to capture everything
important about interpersonal
interaction in organizations
you need not two, but three
categories.
No, actually, in all
seriousness, there's a good
amount of evidence across
industries and across cultures
that there are three fundamental
motives that
people bring to their
interactions.
I call them reciprocity styles,
basically trying to
capture the way that you
approach your interactions
with other people into
exchanging value.
On one end of the reciprocity
spectrum we have the takers.
The people that we all love to
hate who try to get as much as
possible from others and try to
shirk having to contribute
back and often specialize in
things like relentless self
promotion, hogging credit, and
maybe stepping on a few people
on their way to the top.
Now, on the other end of the
spectrum we have these very,
very strange characters
that I call givers.
And for some odd reason, they
actually enjoy helping others.
Not necessarily philanthropists
or volunteers,
but rather the kinds of people
who do a lot of knowledge
sharing, who are always
introducing people and making
connections, who may step
up to provide mentoring.
Now, very few of us
fall purely in the
taker or giver category.
Most people, it turns out, if
you look at the data, are what
I call matchers.
And a matcher is somebody who
has tried to keep an even
balance of give and take.
Quid pro quo.
Tit for tat.
If I do you a favor, I expect
you to do me one in return.
And that seems like a safe and
reasonable way to live your
professional life.
But my question is, is it the
best way to live your
professional life?
Is being a matcher, which most
people choose to do, actually
the best path to success?
I'm going to try to shed some
light on that today.
But before we do that, let's
dive into the takers a little
bit and say, how would you
recognize a taker even if you
didn't know that person?
So I prepared a little test,
first of all, for you to
figure out if you yourself
are a taker.
If you could take a moment and
take the test, I'll tell you
whether you passed.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
ADAM GRANT: Now, I hope this is
the only thing I will say
today that is not based
on data or evidence.
But I sincerely believe that
the longer it takes you to
laugh, the worse your score
is on the taker spectrum.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: Obviously, there are
a couple different paths
to becoming a taker.
One is to be a narcissistic,
to be insecure, to believe
that you have to be superior to
others to be successful and
carry around this assumption
that the world is zero sum.
A second path to becoming a
taker, which I want to talk a
little bit about today, is
having been taken advantage of
one too many times as a matcher
or a giver, and
believing if I don't put
myself first in this
dog-eat-dog competitive
world, nobody will.
There's a third path to becoming
a taker which I'm not
going to talk about today,
it's called being a
psychopath.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: So all right.
How do you spot a taker?
How do you recognize one?
There's an actual study by
Chatterjee and Hambrick
showing that you can tell
whether a CEO is a taker just
by looking at that person's
photograph in a company's
annual report.
Here are photos of two CEOs.
I would argue that one is
a taker, one's a giver.
These guys both built very
successful companies.
Both, interestingly, in the
1970s worked in the Nixon
administration, which I believe
is where one learned
some of his taking habits.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: And the
question is--
these photos were taken right
from their annual reports--
can you tell which of the two
of them is the taker just by
looking at their faces
or their clothing?
Take a second to study them, and
then I'm going to ask you
to weigh in with your votes,
and then justify your bets.
[WHISTLING "JEOPARDY!" THEME]
So as of 2013, most Wharton
undergrads don't recognize
that music.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: Which I find
to be a great tragedy.
Like, is that "The Twilight
Zone?" No.
All right, how many people
think the guy on your
right is the taker?
How many of you don't
know which one is
the guy on your right?
No, OK.
Show your hands again, the
guy on your right.
The taker.
Show your hands high, we want
to know who you are.
OK.
Why?
Why do you think
he's the taker?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well, his eyes
look less kind.
ADAM GRANT: His eyes.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: So you can see
kindness in the eyes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I'm going with what I have.
ADAM GRANT: Who are you, and
where can I learn that skill?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: So I'm told that
that may be a built-in feature
to the Google Glasses.
But what about the eyes signals
kindness to you?
AUDIENCE: I don't--
I'm also completely basing
this off like my exp--
ADAM GRANT: Rightfully so.
What else could you use?
I've given you no information.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I feel like the
one on the left, they're a
little more closed.
Not squinting, but
just more narrow.
ADAM GRANT: All right.
So you feel like the guy on the
right, the taker, is sort
of looking you right
in the eye?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's like he's
posing for a commercial.
ADAM GRANT: He's posing
for a commercial.
Or a press photo shoot.
Yeah.
So there's an actual study
by Keith Campbell and his
colleagues looking at spotting
takers on Facebook.
They look at the narcissistic
variety of takers, and they
show that takers actually post
vainer profile pictures of
themselves.
They're not necessarily more
attractive human beings in
general, but you will find a
greater distance between how
they look every day and how hot
they are in their profile
photo, because they have
to put that best
foot forward, right?
All right.
So that's one interesting cue.
What else do you see about the
man on the right that signals
that man is a taker?
He's selfish.
He's egotistical.
Now no one wants to answer.
But yes, right here.
AUDIENCE: I think his smile
looks a little forced.
ADAM GRANT: The smile
looks forced.
How so?
AUDIENCE: It's like tense.
ADAM GRANT: It's tense.
So you think that he's hiding
something behind it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ADAM GRANT: Maybe All right,
that's reasonable.
Some people also look to this
smile and say he's baring his
teeth, and in the
animal kingdom
that's a sign of dominance.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: And clearly
CEOs live in the
animal kingdom, so.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: Any other cues?
John Carmel, what
about the eyes?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
ADAM GRANT: I know you've
been well trained
to look at the eyes.
AUDIENCE: I don't remember.
ADAM GRANT: Ugh.
Anybody use the eyes other than
just general kindness?
A more specific cue?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The guy on the left
looks like he's making direct
eye contact, the one on the
right looks like he's looking
a little bit above you.
ADAM GRANT: Yeah.
All right.
That's a possibility.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM GRANT: A-ha!
Bring it on.
AUDIENCE: It's when you're doing
a fake smile your eyes
lie because I think they
crinkle right here.
ADAM GRANT: They
don't crinkle.
AUDIENCE: Or don't crinkle.
ADAM GRANT: Yes.
So some of you know the French
neurologist Duchenne in the
1800s discovered the Duchenne
smile, the authentic smile.
You can't control these muscles
right next to your
eyes, and so when you're
experiencing genuine positive
emotions you will see those
crinkle or wrinkle next to
your smile.
But if it's a fake smile,
you won't see those.
The problem is both takers and
givers and matchers, too, are
capable of fake smiles.
In fact, there are a lot of
takers, also, who engage in
very genuine smiles.
There's a term in psychology
called duping delight, which
captures the sheer joy you
experience if you're a taker
after lying to somebody and
getting away with it.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: So you can see this
very genuine smile from a
taker who's like, I just took
you to the cleaners.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: All right.
So those are a couple cues.
I am sorry to report that the
man on the right I would say
is the giver.
So some of you will be
feeling bad about
yourselves right now.
Please don't.
I will make the rest of
you feel bad about
yourselves in a moment.
The guy on the right, some of
you may have heard of him, his
name is Jon Huntsman, Sr. He
built the building that I
teach in at Wharton.
He's one of 19 people on Earth
who have given away over $1
billion dollars.
Seemingly pretty generous.
He also had a son recently
who may have been a
presidential candidate.
If you've read his book "Winners
Never Cheat," he has
some incredible stories of going
out of his way to give
to others, including after the
financial markets crashed, he
couldn't fulfill all of his
charitable commitments so he
took out a personal loan to
deliver on his promises to
help various causes.
There's also a couple stories,
actually, of him being in big
merger and acquisition
negotiations and ending up
feeling like the CEO at the
other side of the table is in
a really bad situation,
had just lost
his wife due to cancer--
cancer, unfortunately,
has affected a lot of
the Huntsman family--
and Huntsman basically signed a
deal instead of claiming an
extra $200 million because he
empathized with the other guy.
So I think he's a pretty
powerful example of a giver.
The man on the left I would
say was the taker.
Did anybody recognize him?
AUDIENCE: Ken Lay.
ADAM GRANT: OK, those
of you who
recognized him, that's cheating.
You can't use actual information
about him.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: You're supposed to
use the photo and the clothes.
But yeah, Ken Lay.
What do you know
about Ken Lay?
AUDIENCE: Enron.
ADAM GRANT: Enron.
Yeah, one of the primary
villains in that scandal.
If you've seen or read "The
Smartest Guys in the Room,"
you've been exposed to many,
many examples of him having
been a taker.
Now, the question is, how did
you know, if you didn't
recognize him, that
he was a taker?
And I'm sad to report that there
is nothing in either of
these two photos that
says anything
about givers and takers.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: I just like to see
what people are willing to
read into meaningless
photographs.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: No, in all
seriousness, I show you these
photos for two reasons.
One, to remind you that when we
judge is somebody a giver
or a taker, are they generous
and helpful, or are they
selfish, we tend to rely a
lot on intuition, on snap
judgments, on the thin slices
that Malcolm Gladwell wrote
about in "Blink." The problem
is these are often wildly
inaccurate, because somebody's
outer veneer--
are they friendly?
Are they warm?
Are they welcoming?
Are they polite?--
is totally different from
their inner motives.
And Ken Lay is a great example
of this, right?
He wasn't just a taker, he was a
faker, ie, a taker disguised
as a giver.
He donated 1% of Enron's annual
profits to charity.
He went out of his way to do
what translates from Dutch to
kissing up, kicking down.
Takers are really good fakers
when dealing with superiors.
They want to put their best
feet forward, they want to
make a good impression
on powerful people.
But it's hard to maintain
that masquerade at every
interaction.
And so even if his bosses were
fooled, oftentimes his peers
and his subordinates saw
right through him.
But I believe we didn't have
to go to his peers and
subordinates to find out
that he was a taker.
I think we could have looked
at the 1997 Enron annual
report, four years before the
company collapsed, and spot a
cue that Ken Lay was a taker.
Let me show you these
photos in context.
Here's Huntsman's
photo from his
company's 2006 annual report.
What do you think Ken Lay's
photo looked like?
Some people are saying
it's a little bigger.
That would be a dramatic
understatement.
Because if you look at the Enron
1997 annual report, you
will notice that his head
is an entire page.
AUDIENCE:
[LAUGHTER AND GROANING]
ADAM GRANT: Now, lest you think
this is just sort of a
fun, unusual example, an
outlier, when Chatterjee and
Hambrick did their research,
they got data on over 100
computer companies.
They got Wall Street analysts
who knew the CEOs of each of
those companies to rate how
much of a taker is each of
those CEOs.
How egotistical?
How selfish?
How narcissistic?
And then they looked for cues
that correlated with the Wall
Street analyst's ratings.
And they found three cues that
actually correlated at 0.86, a
whopping correlation in the
social sciences, with the
ratings given by the analysts.
And one of them was the
prominence of the CEO's photo
in the annual report.
The taker CEOs actually
had larger photos.
They were more likely to be
pictured alone, as well.
Which sent a clear
message, right?
I am the most important person
in this company.
It is all about me.
Second cue--
compensation.
The average computer industry
CEO made about two to two and
a half times the annual salary
of the next highest paid
executive in that company.
The average taker CEO had a
multiple of what greater than
the next highest paid executive
in the company?
AUDIENCE: 40.
ADAM GRANT: 40.
I mean, I'm not even sure if
that's financially possible.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: It was a
multiple of seven.
So taker CEOs got paid about
seven times more than anybody
else in their company.
Third cue was in their speech.
Not just larger photos, not
just bigger relative pay.
What two words do taker CEOs
use more than the others?
AUDIENCE: "I" and "me?"
ADAM GRANT: "I" and
"me," bingo.
When talking about the company,
as opposed to "us"
and we." So those are a
couple ways that you
could recognize a taker.
What I want to do, though, is
I want to ask, OK, what
happens to takers?
Do they rise?
Do they fall?
How does their success compare
to givers and matchers?
And when I started trying to ask
this question, I began at
the bottom of success, asking
which group is worst off.
Who gets the worst results?
Is it the takers, the givers,
or the matchers?
And it looked at research
in three domains.
First, engineers.
Got to have engineers.
Stanford's Frank Flynn did this
great study where he got
engineers to rate each other
on how many favors they did
versus how many they got,
and then tracked their
productivity and the number
of errors they made.
And then medical students.
Filip Lievens and his colleagues
got every medical
student in Belgium over a seven
year period to fill out
surveys about how much they
liked helping others and then
tracked their grades.
And then Dane Barnes and I
actually studied salespeople.
And we were interested
in revenue.
So who were the highest
producing salespeople who
bring in the most revenue
every year?
Across these three groups, the
same results came out.
The engineers, the medical
students, and the salespeople.
There was one group, either the
takers, the givers, or the
matchers, who was consistently
worse off when it came to
productivity, errors,
grades, and revenue.
Get a show of hands to see
where your intuitions and
assumptions lie.
How many people think
it was the takers at
the bottom most often?
All right, we have some
optimists in the room.
How many people think
it was the matchers?
OK, a lot of you.
Now, this is an odd thing
to vote for, because
statistically if most people
are matchers, it would
actually be quite hard for
most people to be at the
bottom of any metric.
What about the givers?
How many people think the givers
are at the bottom?
All right, those of you
with your hands up,
you would be correct.
If you looked at the engineers,
the engineers with
the worst productivity and the
most mistakes were those who
did a lot more favors
than they got back.
They were so busy helping
their colleagues, they
couldn't get their work done
efficiently or effectively.
Medical students.
The students with the worst
grades in year one of medical
school were the ones who agreed
most strongly with
statements like, I love
helping others.
Now, if you carry that to
its logical extreme--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: The doctor that
you trust is somebody who
never wanted to help anyone.
Salespeople.
Dane and I found that the
salespeople with the lowest
revenue were the ones also who
were passionately motivated to
help their colleagues and
help their customers.
And I had one salespeople put
it to me pretty bluntly.
He said, look, I really want
to help my customers, which
means I will never sell
them a product.
So I found this to
be interesting.
I also found it, for those of
you who are givers, to be a
little bit sad.
How many of you would
self-identify more as a giver
than a matcher or a taker?
OK, how many of you
self-identify as a giver but
didn't want to raise your hand
because you feel like that
violates humility?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: All right,
those are the real
givers in the room.
So I did think this was sad,
though, for those people who
are givers.
And so then I wanted to
know who's at the top.
If the givers are at the bottom,
then who's the most
likely to have the highest
productivity, the fewest
mistakes, the best grades,
and, ultimately, the most
revenue and sales?
Get a show of hands on
this one as well.
How many people think
the takers were most
likely at the top?
How many people think the
matchers are most likely at
the top, ignoring my warning
that the most common can't be
overrepresented in one
part of the spectrum?
How many people didn't raise
their hand for either the
takers or the matchers
just now?
OK, good, now we have
everyone involved.
Maybe you didn't raise your
hand because you already
anticipated the thing that took
me 10 years to figure
out, which is it's
the givers again.
The givers are not only
overrepresented at the bottom,
they're also more common
at the top.
The engineers not only with the
worst results but also the
best results are the ones
who do a lot more favors
than they get back.
The takers and the matchers are
more likely to be in the
middle when it comes to
their productivity
and their error rates.
Medical students with the best
grades, not just in year one
but over a seven year period are
also the ones who say, I
love helping others.
And by the way, the medical
students seem to get better
over time when they're givers,
because you move from
basically having to study
information independently to
collaborating with fellow
physicians and also having to
work closely with patients.
And givers tend to really shine
in interdependent work,
whereas they may struggle
a little bit more
in independent work.
In sales, Dane and I found that
giver salespeople who
really loved helping colleagues
and customers
actually brought in about 50%
more annual revenue than the
takers and the matchers.
So for me, that posed
two questions.
One was, what do successful
givers do that the rest of us
takers and matchers might
want to learn?
And I think this is an exciting
question because
these reciprocity styles
are not hard wired.
They're not fixed.
In fact, they're choices
we make in every single
interaction.
As a thought experiment,
think about the next
person that you meet.
And you could say, I'm going
to ask myself, do I want to
just try to help this person
with no strings attached?
Do I want to try to get
something from this person?
Or do I want to make
an even trade?
And the more that you make
those choices, the more
obviously you define yourself
by one style or another.
But because it's a choice, it's
something we can all change.
And maybe there are ways that
successful givers operate that
would be interesting
and productive
for takers and matchers.
Second question that I was
curious about is, what happens
to those givers at the bottom?
And if you would like to be a
helpful person or a generous
person, what are the traps that
you might fall into and
how do you avoid them?
Took me a couple hundred
pages to try to
answer those questions.
I'm not going to put you all
through that this morning.
But what I want to do is just
give you a couple highlights
of some of the things that I
learned that are described in
more detail in the book.
Overall, the thing that I was
really interested in is how do
givers who succeed relate
to the people in their
organizations or outside
of them?
And so I end up looking at how
do givers build networks?
How do they collaborate?
How do they develop talent
in other people?
How do they communicate and
influence and negotiate?
And I'll just give you a couple
of stories and data
points from a few of those
perspectives, and then we can
open it up for questions.
So collaboration.
How do givers succeed
in collaboration?
Anybody recognize this man?
He's known as the genius behind
the most successful
television show in history.
AUDIENCE: "Muppets."
ADAM GRANT: No, but
it's a good guess.
Probably you've never
heard of him.
I hadn't heard of him either
when I came across his story.
Although I later found out that
he invented a word that
was uttered by my college
roommate every day for four
years, which made me a
little bit unhappy.
But this man is known as the
genius behind a really amazing
television show.
And he had a pretty
checkered past.
He was an undergraduate, and he
ended up deciding that he
was going to sell
a refrigerator.
And he sold it to a freshman,
and he took the money, and he
never delivered the
refrigerator.
And he almost got kicked out of
college for that, and then
he almost got kicked out again
when he smashed his dorm room
window with an electric
guitar.
And his one sort of
crowning moment in
life was when he was--
to that point, at least--
elected the president of "The
Harvard Lampoon." But
then he was--
actually there was an attempted
overthrow, a coup,
by his peers because he was
quote "not responsible
enough."
And he ended up finishing
college.
He decided that he was going to
make a living by betting on
dog racing, greyhound tracks.
And he spent two weeks holed in
a library trying to develop
a mathematic, scientific way
of beating the system.
Unfortunately, he ran out of
money a few days later and had
to move in with his parents.
So bad start to his career.
But somehow he managed to get
a job writing for a little
show called "Saturday Night
Live" in the 1980s.
And one point in his "Saturday
Night Live" career-- his name
is George Meyer, by the way.
George had a decision to make.
He had two different
guests that were
coming onto the show.
One of them, the Material Girl
in the height of her
fame, in her prime.
The other we will say perhaps a
less desirable candidate to
write a sketch for,
Jimmy Breslin.
And George was trying to
figure out, OK, we need
sketches for both
of these people.
They're going to be coming
on the show.
And everybody's flocking
to write for Madonna.
Nobody wants to write
for Jimmy Breslin.
They don't think he's very
fun or entertaining.
And George says,
you know what?
One of the best ways to be
successful if you're working
in a team or a group is to
try to make other people
successful.
If "Saturday Night Live" is
better, then I'm going to be
better off too because
I'm a part of that.
And so he engages in what gets
called at the National Outdoor
Leadership School expedition
behavior.
Basically saying, if you're
going to go and climb a
mountain, try and put the
mission ahead of your own
personal interests
and desires.
And he says, you know what?
I'm going to submit a few
sketches for Madonna, but I'm
going to do my best work
for Jimmy Breslin.
And that's really where my work
is needed, because so few
people are wanting to contribute
good ideas there.
And George ends up writing
this amazing skit.
It's called "Bond Villains on
a Talk Show." And you get to
see basically Breslin playing
a Bond Villain, and they're
comparing strategies
for attacking Bond.
And that ends up basically
inspiring Mike Myers to do the
"Austin Powers" movies, which
was kind of a cool thing to
see happen.
Well, if you look at what
happened to George next, he
ended up moving out
to Colorado.
He was working on a
Letterman script.
It didn't pan out, and he
decided he wanted to do his
own comedy.
And he knew he couldn't do it
alone, so he reaches out to a
bunch of his "Saturday
Night Live" buddies.
And he was really torn about how
to do this, because for a
lot of people George is a really
funny guy and he would
be a threat.
Right?
You're working in this zero sum
sort of competitive world
of comedy, there are
only so many jobs.
And George is afraid that if
he reaches out to people
they're not going to help him
because if he succeeds, that
means they're going to fail.
But one of the things that
happened when George engaged
in this kind of expedition
behavior is he showed that he
was the kind of person who
cared about the group.
He cared about other
people's interests.
And as a result, instead of
gunning for him, people wanted
to support him.
He kind of established himself
as a giver, and as a result,
people were kind of rooting
for him when he was doing
work, and they wanted to feel
like this is the kind of guy
who deserved to succeed.
Part of the reason for that is
most people are matchers.
And if you're a matcher, you
believe in a just world.
You think what goes around
ought to come around.
And that means when you see a
taker acting selfishly, you
want to punish that person.
Usually that means, Robb Willer
shows at Stanford,
gossiping--
sharing negative reputational
information so that takers
cannot get away with exploiting
other people.
Just as you can't stand to see
a taker be selfish and get
away with it, you also, if
you're a matcher, don't like
to see generous people fail.
And so when somebody's a giver
and really helpful, you will
often go on a mission to plot
that person's well being.
And I think that's exactly what
happened to George Meyer.
All these colleagues came out of
the woodwork and they said,
yeah, we'll contribute.
George wanted to write this
little magazine called "Army
Man." It was going to be a
parody of the US military.
And he reached out to all of
these colleagues, and they
just gave away some of their
best comedy to him for free.
One of them was a guy
named Jack Handey.
And he wrote one of his earliest
"Deep Thoughts"
pieces two years before it ever
appeared on the show for
George and his little
"Army Man" magazine.
George puts out the magazine.
It has all this great
comedy in it.
It catches the attention of a
guy by the name of Sam Simon,
and Sam is just about to start
a little TV show called "The
Simpsons."
George ends up getting invited
because of this comedy he was
able to do to "The Simpsons,"
where he becomes an executive
producer, wins a bunch of Emmys,
ends up contributing to
a movie that grossed half a
billion dollars, and has a
pretty good, successful
career.
What's interesting, though, is
that he contributed to over
300 "Simpsons" episodes, and
he only took credit as a
writer on 12 of them.
And I think this was part
of his giver style.
But I think one of the things
that Robb Willer points out in
his research is that groups
reward individual sacrifice.
And this is one of the ways
that givers succeed in
collaboration--
looking for the unpopular tasks
and volunteering for
them, and showing that they
actually care about the best
interests of the group.
And then when it comes time to
determine who should lead, who
deserves opportunities, those
are the people who get
rewarded and trusted
and respected.
So that's one example of the
kind of thing that we see
givers do successfully
in collaboration.
Now, some people will look at
this and say, this is crazy.
This is not something that I
would recommend to somebody
that I cared about.
And if this video clip works,
I want to show you my first
introduction to how most
people view givers.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Huh.
Still a 31 waist?
-Yep.
Since college.
Hey, Lena's Small's
on this list.
-Lena Small?
-Yeah.
She's that girl I was going
to call for a date.
She was unlisted, and now
here's her number.
-Oh, you are not gonna cop a
girl's phone number off an
AIDS charity list.
-Elaine, you should admire me.
I'm aspiring to date
a giving person.
[LAUGHTER]
-But you're a taking person.
-That's why I should date
a giving person.
If I date a taking person,
everyone's
taking, taking, taking.
No one's giving.
It's bedlam.
So George.
-Yeah.
-Guess what?
Lena found out how
I got her number.
-Really?
How'd she do that?
-Eh, friend of a friend
of Susan's.
-My Susan?
-(SHOUTING) Why'd you tell her?
[LAUGHTER]
-I had to, Jerry.
It's a couple rule.
We have to tell each
other everything.
-Well, you know what this
means, don't you?
-What?
-You're cut off.
You're out of the loop.
[LAUGHTER]
-You're cut-- you're
cuting me off?
No, no, no, Jerry,
don't cut me off.
-You leave me no choice.
You're the media now as
far as I'm concerned.
-No, Jerry, come on.
Please.
It won't happen again.
-If you were in the mafia, would
you tell her every time
you killed someone?
-Hey, a hit is a totally
different story.
[LAUGHTER]
-I don't know, George.
-So Lena was upset, huh?
-You know what?
That was the amazing thing.
-What, it didn't bother her?
-No, she said it was fine.
Something very strange
about this girl.
-What?
-She's too good.
-Too good?
-I mean, she's giving and caring
and genuinely concerned
about the welfare of others.
I can't be with someone
like that.
[LAUGHTER]
-I see what you mean.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ADAM GRANT: I think that's
how a lot of people
view givers, right?
It's a sign of weakness.
But I actually think it can
be a source of strength.
And one of the more interesting
ways that plays
out is to look at how givers
actually communicate.
I had a chance to get a personal
taste of this.
A few years ago, shortly after I
finished my doctorate, I was
asked to teach a group of
Air Force colonels.
And I was supposed to teach them
how to lead and motivate.
I was in my mid-20s, and most of
them were in their mid-50s.
They were just like the guys out
of "Top Gun." Most of them
had flown thousands of hours
and had these really pretty
badass nicknames like Stealth
and Gunner and Iceman.
And I walked in, and I knew that
I needed to establish my
credentials, right?
Here was this kid,
half their age.
And so I started talking a
little bit about my expertise,
my experience, why I could maybe
share some knowledge
that would be helpful to them.
And it was a four-hour
experience, and I got the
feedback from the
teaching forums.
And it was pretty
darn painful.
Some of the comments
have really burned
themselves into my brain.
But the one that really stuck
out the most was quote, "More
knowledge in the audience than
on the podium." It's like,
that is very sad.
Thank you.
The others were nicer, but
they said similar things.
One person said, gosh,
the professors get
younger every year.
How can they possibly know
anything about leadership when
they've never led, let
alone had a real job.
And I was like, OK.
So part of what I realized
there was that I was
communicating a little bit
more like a taker does.
Takers try to get respect
by gaining dominance.
They try to be as confident
as possible.
They try to make sure
there are not any
chinks in their armor.
And they want to make sure, as a
result, that people see them
very positively.
And that style didn't feel
very comfortable for me.
As a professor, at least, I felt
like my job was always to
listen to students, to learn
from them, and then try to
figure out what I knew that
might be helpful.
And so I had another session
with a different group of Air
Force colonels scheduled before
they decided to fire me
altogether.
And this time I decided that
instead of going with the
really powerful, confident
approach, I would do something
a little bit more powerless.
And I opened up by saying, OK,
guys, I know what some of you
are thinking right now.
What can I possibly learn
from a professor
who's 12 years old?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: And there was
this dead silence.
And one of the guys I was pretty
sure started to reach
for his gun.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: And then they all
started laughing, and one of
them said, oh, there's
no way you're 12.
I'm sure you're at least 13.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: And that sort of
became a running joke for the
next four hours.
And I noticed that I had really
bonded with the audience.
I think part of it was because
I had called out the elephant
in the room.
But afterward when I read
the feedback, it
was night and day.
A lot of them said, gosh, it was
a breath of fresh air to
have a young professor who
could talk about the
millennial generation.
And I think that a lot of it--
I delivered the exact
same material.
A lot of it was the
vulnerability and humility to
say, look, I don't have
all the answers.
And I may not be able to teach
you guys anything.
And if you look at the data on
this, givers are a lot more
comfortable doing that
than takers.
Takers do not want to expose
their weaknesses, whereas
givers are willing to
communicate in a much more
authentic and honest, maybe even
self-deprecating way in
order to form a genuine
connection with the people
that they're trying
to connect with.
And I think there's a great
example of this that dates
back to the mid-1800s.
Somebody that you may
have heard of, Abe
Lincoln, was in a debate.
And his opponent called him
"two-faced." And I think a lot
of takers would have been
offended by that.
I think that Lincoln was a
really extraordinary example
of a giver who was always
looking for other people's
best interests and how to
pursue and support them.
And he didn't even really
skip a beat.
And he said, "You call
me two-faced.
If I had another face, do you
really think I would wear this
one?"
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: And it's a great
example of that kind of
vulnerability and humility that
establishes a connection.
I think that Lincoln was really
clever about it, too.
He knew that his appearance was
something easy to laugh
at, but also that it was not
going to call into question
his competence.
And so it was something that
he could easily be a little
bit vulnerable about.
There's a classic study that
shows why this works.
Elliot Aronson in the 1960s
asked people to listen to
tapes of "Quiz Bowl" experts.
Some of them were extremely
knowledgeable, others didn't
really have the answers to the
trivia questions that were
being posed to them.
And you're listening to this
tape, you hear this candidate
answering all these
questions right.
And then some of the candidates
the tape just ends,
and then others spill some
coffee on themselves and you
hear the cup crash and the
person's like, oh my
gosh, I'm so clumsy.
And you actually, it turns
out, like and respect the
"Quiz Bowl" expert more when he
spills coffee on himself.
So Aronson and his colleagues
call this the pratfall effect.
And they say, look, we actually
identify with people
more when they're human.
But interestingly, it doesn't
work if the person is not
"Quiz Bowl" competent.
So if you got most of the
questions wrong and you
spilled coffee on yourself, you
just look like an idiot.
But I think that this is a lot
of what happens when givers
communicate.
There's some really good
research by Alison Fragale at
the University of North Carolina
who shows that we
tend to think that powerful
speech, the confident, the
assertive, the dominant, is
going to earn us status and
trust and respect.
But that that's only true
if you're really working
independently, separately.
If you have to collaborate, you
have to work in a team, or
you have to have clients, you
will actually get more trust
if you use a lot of ums and uhs
and ifs and hesitations
and tag lines and qualifiers,
because what happens is when
you speak in a more tentative,
soft-spoken way, people tend
to assume that you have their
best interests at heart.
And guess what?
In a collaboration, we care at
least as much about whether
you care about my best interests
as whether you're
competent and capable
and assertive.
And again, I think this is
something that often works
really well for givers
as they communicate.
This willingness to defer to
other people, to show an
interest in other people's
opinions
while they're talking.
Those are a couple of things
on communication I thought
were interesting.
One other thing I wanted
to highlight--
burnout.
Teacher burnout.
Common problem.
This is Conrey Callahan.
She was a Teach for America
teacher who probably
experienced the worst burnout
I've ever seen in a classroom.
She has at Overbook High School
in Philadelphia where
the graduation rate is abysmally
low, the crime rate
is extremely high.
There are students who actually
only come to school
two or three days a year.
And she was just exhausted
by these students
who wouldn't listen.
And somehow she managed to turn
that around and actually
end up getting a National
Teaching Award and stay longer
with Teach for America
than any of the
people in her cohort.
And when I started to interview
her about why, she
said some things that I thought
tracked really well
with some recent data.
The first thing she said was at
the height of her burnout
she was getting up at 6:00 AM,
she was working 'til 1:00 AM
usually, she was having to do
grading on the weekends.
Instead of giving less,
she gave more.
She started a nonprofit
organization called Minds
Matter Philadelphia,
where she was
tutoring kids on the weekends.
And I was like, how could you
possibly burnout less by
giving more?
That, I think, defies every
principle of physics and
chemistry I've ever learned.
And she said, well, part of
what happened was in my
everyday job I don't feel like
I necessarily make a dent.
I don't think I have
an impact.
Whereas when I'm working with
these kids on the weekends,
these are high-achieving
low income kids.
And I feel like I spend four or
five hours with them, and
I'm actually helping them
get into college.
And it renews my hope that
my regular teaching
job can have an impact.
And I think it reveals one
of the really interesting
principles of giver burnout.
Givers don't burnout just
because they're working too
hard or giving too much.
They burnout when they don't
get to feel that they're
making the difference that
they had set out to make.
And I think that Conrey's idea
of starting this nonprofit was
a really interesting way of not
only seeing more of her
impact by trying to help
people who were really
dedicated to school, but also
just created sort of a fresh
experience of being in a
different setting and being
able to renew a little
bit of energy.
The other thing she did that I
think was really clever was
she chunked her giving into
blocks, as opposed to
sprinkling it out
across the day.
There's an experiment by Sonja
Lyubomirsky that looks at
random acts of kindness.
And you are either randomly
assigned to do one random act
of kindness every day for a week
or five random acts of
kindness in one day each week.
And most people assume that you
should do them every day,
and that way you feel like
you're helpful every day and
that will boost your
happiness.
But Sonja finds the opposite,
that doing five random acts of
kindness in one day actually
leads to greater happiness
than doing one each
day for five days.
We can speculate about
why that is.
I think this research
is relatively new.
But one of Sonja's dominant
explanations is that you feel
like you are actually
having an impact.
When you do five acts of
meaningful helping a day, they
add up, whereas when you
sprinkle them around it's sort
of a drop in the bucket, and it
doesn't make you feel like
you're truly making
a difference.
I think that that's a really
interesting practice.
So there's one Fortune 500
company that actually goes out
of its way to set quiet time
windows-- this is Leslie
Perlow's research at Harvard
Business School--
to say if you are an engineer,
you're constantly interrupting
and getting interrupted by
your colleagues, and it's
really hard to get your
own work done.
So what if Tuesdays, Thursdays,
and Friday mornings
from 9:00 to 12:00 there were no
interruptions and you could
get your own work done.
And then you have these windows
set aside where you
can be helpful and
support others.
When Leslie did that, this
particular company had 66% of
engineers show above average
productivity.
And at the end of the day they
launched their product, which
was a laser printer, on time
for only the second time in
division history.
And I think this, again,
illustrates some things that
givers can do to
avoid burnout.
Don't help all the people
all the time
with all the requests.
Don't drop everything to support
the people around you,
but rather say I'm going to
reserve windows where I'm
going to be helpful to the
people around me, and then
also I'm going to have times
that I block out for my own
individual work.
Those are some of the things
that I wanted to talk about.
Just a few other things you
might find in the book if you
are curious.
How do givers build networks,
and how do those look
different from takers
and matchers?
How does "Fortune's"
best networker--
the guy, not the cat--
claim that he built an
extraordinary network?
Some of you may know this man.
Just through random
acts of kindness.
And does it actually work?
Leadership.
How does this guy, CJ Skender,
an accounting professor,
because he's a giver, know
that this woman, Beth
Traynham, whose own mother told
her she couldn't add or
tell time, would one day
become a national gold
medalist in accounting?
And how did he know that this
guy, Reggie Love, who was
written off by many as an
athlete, would one day become
President Obama's body man?
What do givers know about
spotting talent in others that
takers and matchers
miss out on?
Decision making.
Why does a basketball executive
named Stu Inman pass
up the chance to choose Michael
Jordan and end up
getting a draft bust, Sam Bowie,
and then hang on to Sam
Bowie for four years instead
of cutting his losses?
What does it take to get other
people to avoid the trap that
psychologists call escalation
of commitment to a losing
course of action and instead
say, you know what, it's over
man, just let her go?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER[
ADAM GRANT: I know sometimes
that one hits a little too
close to home.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: And then how do you
avoid being treated as a
doormat if you're a giver?
What prevents you from
becoming a pushover?
How do you deal with a taker and
still maintain your sense
of concern for others
and generosity?
But my favorite question, is
it possible to turn a taker
into a giver?
Maybe not in all of their
interactions, right?
But can we nudge people more in
the giving direction in our
relationships with them?
Maybe.
One of my favorite ways to do
that, some of you have been
part of already, it's called the
reciprocity ring, invented
by Wayne Baker at the University
of Michigan and
Cheryl Baker at Humax
Networks.
The idea is you gather a group
of 10 or 20 or 30 people, and
you ask them all to
make a request.
Something meaningful, personal,
or professional that
they want but can't
get on their own.
And then you ask everybody else
in the group just to try
to use their knowledge and their
networks to make the
request happen.
And some pretty amazing things
happen when everybody adopts
the norm of giving and says,
we're just going to all try to
support each other.
Couple examples.
Earlier this year a woman came
in said, my hero is a man
who's a blogger, but he's
also a minimalist.
And he's impossible to
contact because he
likes a simple life.
I've wanted for six years to
meet him and one, thank him,
and two, ask him how
I can help him.
But I don't know how to
get in touch with him.
Could anybody help me?
And one person in this room
says, yeah, you know what?
I know a blogger
who knows him.
And they've been introduced,
and they're meeting up for
dinner next week.
I'm very excited to
see how it goes.
I think it probably wouldn't
have happened unless she had
access to this network of people
who in that moment were
willing to act like givers.
And guess what?
Because the requests are
visible, it's really hard to
be a taker.
Because when you make that ask,
if you don't help other
people, nobody wants
to support you.
There are a few people in this
room who were present for this
particular request in my
classroom when a student named
Michelle said she had a friend
who had her growth stunted as
a child and she could never find
the right clothing, could
anybody help her?
And another student, Jessica,
raised her hand, and she said,
yeah, I have an uncle in
the garment business.
And I'm happy to reach
out to him.
And three months later,
custom clothing
arrived on her doorstep.
And for the first time in the
life of Hope, Michelle's
friend, she actually had
clothing that fit her right.
My favorite request, though,
of all time was a student
named Alex who came in one day
we were running one of these
reciprocity ring exercises.
And he said, I think the closest
thing to nirvana in
life is riding a
roller coaster.
And I came to Wharton because I
one day would love to run a
place like Six Flags.
But strangely, Six Flags does
not recruit at the Wharton
School of Business.
So could anybody help me figure
out how to break into
the industry?
Another student, Andrew, raises
his hand and says,
yeah, I think my dad knows the
ex-CEO, I'm happy to get you
guys in touch.
Two weeks later, they have a
cell conversation, and Alex
comes into class the next day.
I'm so excited to find
out about it.
So Alex, how'd it go?
And Alex was like, I learned
something really important
from that conversation--
I will never want to work
in that industry ever.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: And I was like, OK,
at least you were able to
rule that out.
And because of that, I am proud
to say that today, at
this very moment, Alex is
living his dream happily
employed as a management
consultant.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: Anyway, I'm
happy to talk further.
If you check out the "Give and
Take" site, you can rate
yourself on a survey and figure
out do you tend to
think most like a giver,
a taker, or a matcher?
Although you all know too much
now, so your ratings will be
fatally flawed.
There's also a 360 assessment.
You can anonymously ask anybody
who knows who to rate
you, and then basically find out
do I see myself the same
way other people see me?
And then there's also a Nominate
a Giver feature, sort
of like a bigger version of
the way that peer and spot
bonuses often work, where you
can write a little paragraph
to recognize somebody
that you think
has been really generous.
And we're going to basically
recognize one a week based on
voting for the best example
of a successful giver.
All right, happy to open
it up for questions.
Who's the first victim?
Tina, "Is there a difference
between men and women?" In
general, or in "Give
and Take?"
AUDIENCE: "Give and Take."
ADAM GRANT: Yeah.
I really try to avoid this
question, because I wanted to
write about people,
not sort of divide
the world by genders.
But the data on this I think
are pretty interesting.
So Alice Eagly and her
colleagues have meta-analyzed
about three decades of studies
looking at are men or women
more likely to help others?
And they find that the answer
is no, they're actually
equally likely to be helpful,
but that they specialize in
helping in different domains.
So women tend to do more helping
behaviors in close
relationships.
They spend more time helping
their friends, their family
members, and their
close colleagues.
Whereas men are more likely,
it seems from the data, to
help strangers, especially in
emergency situations, which I
think has an interesting
macho implication.
Oh, I must be tough and
rescue someone now.
Arrr.
But I think a lot of people
stereotype women as being more
likely to be givers because a
lot of the most important
giving that happens in the
world is the close
relationship based giving, and
I would love to see more men
acting like women.
AUDIENCE: So you said that for
givers, they're at the bottom
and then at the top.
Has that been filtered out
by intelligence level?
So I'm wondering if you get to
a point where things become
too easy so you start helping
people if you're at the top
versus for some people it might
be you just help because
you know that's something
you can do.
ADAM GRANT: Yeah.
So intelligence is a really
interesting question.
In my data, intelligence are
close to orthogonal--
intelligence measures are to
"Give and Take." So you can
find very, very bright givers,
very bright takers.
There is some evidence.
Russell James, an economist, has
actually shown the smarter
you are, the more you give
to charity, even after
controlling for your education
levels, your
socioeconomic status.
And the idea is basically that
if you're incredibly high in
intellectual horsepower, it's
easier for you to appreciate
all the different ways that you
could be benefiting others
in the long run.
I think there's a lot
a debate about it.
But there's another study
by [? Millet and ?]
DeWitt that actually shows that
when you give people an
intelligence test and then you
ask them to play a prisoner's
dilemma game where they have to
keep money for themselves
or give it to others, the
smarter you are, the more you
give to others.
That being said, the
correlations are so small that
I don't think they're
practically that meaningful.
In the studies that Dane and I
did of salespeople we actually
controlled for intelligence
and found that even after
taking that out of the equation
the giver factor was
basically a very strong
predictor of both hitting the
bottom and the top
of sales revenue.
The other intelligence data
point that I've seen is
there's a great study by Kim and
Glomb called "Get Smarty
Pants" which shows the smarter
you are, the more likely you
are to be bullied by your
colleagues who are jealous,
unless you're a giver.
And that goes back to the point
we want to take down
really bright, successful
takers, but we want to support
and lift up the bright,
successful givers.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
[INAUDIBLE]
things I loved for
the session.
It was really interesting.
Going back to the point of
showing vulnerability
publicly, I was wondering
if that changes
from culture to culture.
Because in certain cultures I
have the feeling that the more
senior or the more professional
you are,
[? public ?] vulnerability might
be seen as something
quite [? narrative ?]
intellectually.
ADAM GRANT: Yeah, I think
there's a huge cross-cultural
difference there.
One of the best ways, I think,
to think about that is to go
back to Hofstede's classic
research on power distance and
say that in cultures where
people accept basically steep
hierarchies as appropriate and
correct, it's a little bit
riskier to open up and
be vulnerable.
I also think, though, that that
was maybe the situations
where it's most powerful and
disarming for somebody that
you expect to have this
incredibly polished
presentation style to actually
open up and say, look, I'm
just human, too.
Aronson's research actually
showed that it will depend on
the audience, though, how
people react to it.
So the people who like those
who sort of spill coffee on
themselves or stumble the most
are those with average
self-esteem.
Those are the people who see
themselves as human, and they
like other people to be human.
Whereas if you have really high
self-esteem, you tend to
want other people to appear
really confident.
If you have low self-esteem,
you just
don't like other people.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: That may be a slight
caricature of the data.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Adam.
Katie Everett, fellow
Harvard diver.
Hi.
I am wondering--
I have my daughter here today,
Grace, who's five.
It's take your child
to work day.
And I love your work and have
been thinking about how do you
foster this kind of mindset
in your children?
I'm just wondering if you have
any insights into how to do
something like that.
ADAM GRANT: Yeah.
First of all, I think it should
be called give your
child to work day, not take.
No.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: I was working
on that all night.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: No.
I think that it's a really
interesting question.
As an organizational
psychologist rather than a
developmental psychologist, it
really stretches far beyond my
areas of expertise.
So I'm more of a consumer
in this area
than I think a producer.
But I've had a lot of fun
reading some of the research
on what causes some people
to grow into givers.
And I'll just highlight
a couple of patterns.
I'm happy to share more details
if anybody wants to
read the studies.
One is parenting styles
are obviously huge.
If you are a role model as a
parent as a giver, obviously
your children are more likely
to follow suit.
Also, there's some really cool
data showing that parents who
end up basically giving their
children a lot of freedom are
more likely to encourage their
children to become givers.
Whereas those who restrict
freedom then essentially raise
kids who want to restrict the
freedom of the other people
around them, which is sort of,
I think, a little bit more of
a taker move.
The other really interesting
data
point on this is siblings.
So this is Paul van
Lange's research.
What Paul shows is that a lot
of people think first borns
are more likely to be givers
because you get a lot of
responsibility training if you
have younger siblings.
You have to share and care
and feed and babysit.
And it's actually the opposite
in a weird sense, which is
just don't be the last born.
As long as you have at least one
younger sibling, and then
the more of them you have, the
more of this responsibility
training you get and the more
you tend to gravitate in the
giver direction.
One other sibling pattern that
I think is really interesting
is van Lange shows that people
who do a lot of generous
giving are twice as likely to
have sisters as brothers.
And you could ask, well, back
to Tina's question, why do
sisters turn us into givers?
And there's a debate
about that.
I don't want to speculate
too far.
But two of the popular
explanations are one, women
basically earlier on start
giving, and so that rubs off
on their siblings.
And then two, there's
some data--
Jonathan Haidt argues that
girl babies are literally
cuter than boy babies, and so
they attract more empathy and
then people want to help them
more, and then they
get into the habit.
Again, this is going very
far beyond data.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: We have one more
question, and then I have two
things I want to
say to wrap up.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was wondering
if you had looked at
how the proportion of givers
and takers can affect the
effectiveness of an entire
organization.
Because one of the things that
I've found since I joined
Google is part of the strengths
is that everyone on
average is much more
helpful than they
are in other companies.
ADAM GRANT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And I think that
really makes the organization
much better, and even
the products that we
produce much better.
ADAM GRANT: Yeah,
I totally agree.
I'm probably preaching
to the choir on this.
So I wrote a little article
that's in "McKinsey Quarterly"
this month that summarizes
some of the evidence.
Probably the most powerful
data point is Nathan
Podsakoff's meta analysis of
organizational citizenship
behaviors looking at when more
employees do a lot of helping
and giving behaviors, what
happens to entire business
units or organizations?
And showing that you can just
take the frequency of helping
between employees on sort of a
daily basis and use that to
predict with surprising power
organizational profits,
efficiency metrics, customer
satisfaction, employee retention.
And I think that this is
actually a big part of
Google's success.
As an outsider, I've just been
amazed by the number of people
who are already givers who come
here, and also the giving
norms that people get
socialized to
right off the bat.
And I think that may be very
well one of the secrets to
this company's success.
So on that note, I want
to say two things.
First of all, thank you
so much for having me.
It's always a real delight and
honor to have the chance to
speak to Googlers.
Because some of you already know
this, but if I knew that
a company like this existed I
probably never would have gone
into academia.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: And it's just
really, really exciting to
work with a company that not
only has a lot of employees
that are givers, but also has
a mission that's so much
about-- well, at least
not taking, right?
If you talk about sort of
the no evil policy.
But also the genuine idea of
actually democratizing
information and making it
available to other people.
It's something that I feel
really passionately about, and
I feel lucky to have the chance
to work with you all.
Second thing I wanted to do is
I think that a lot of people
have a hard time recognizing
successful givers.
Because even in an organization
with a lot of
givers, the takers are
the ones who are
sort of in the spotlight.
And the givers are usually
comfortable sort of hanging
out in the shadows.
And I wanted to try to solve
that problem in two ways.
One is we have some postcards
that you can hand out to
anybody that you think has been
a giver, to recognize
them for that.
Originally they said, "Thank
you for being a giver," and
some people said, oh, that's
kind of cheesy.
Especially men said that.
And so we changed it.
They say, "Congratulations,
you're not a taker."
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ADAM GRANT: So you can
pass those around.
There are more to download on
the "Give and Take" website if
you want them.
The last thing I wanted to do
is just thank some of the
amazing givers who have helped
me a ton with this research
since a lot of you
are in the room.
If I can ask you to stand up
so that we can applaud you.
First of all, the Google People
Analytics folks who are
here, please stand.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM GRANT: So much of the
research in the book and the
ideas in it were shaped by the
work that we've done together,
and in particular Prasad
and Catherine have been
extraordinarily helpful.
Secondly, former students.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM GRANT: In particular, I
want to thank Jackie and Jeff
from the Impact Lab
who actually did
a lot of this research.
And Jackie for telling me that I
should write a book, which I
wouldn't have done had she not
encouraged me to do it.
And then finally,
Amy Reznesky.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM GRANT: I know a lot of you
know Amy already, but she
is the ultimate role
model when it
comes to being a giver.
As a professor, I have learned a
ton from her, and every idea
in the book was already modeled
by her long before I
had a chance to study it.
And I feel incredibly
fortunate to
have her as a colleague.
And she's going to turn really
red, but if you will all thank
her again for me.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM GRANT: Thank you.
You're free to go.